he'll cor around to protect the buck as
Ros L he blew it high Harry panar in front
Suzuki bringing it to the forehand as the
captain looking for his first goal of the
Season John G the give and go G right in front
score rosc buries it in front and Columbus on
the board it is one nothing it's a good job
of stopping in front of the at here good Puck
movement wide and you see how much Zach rinsky
means to this team offensively little give and go
with Johnny gdo and then just a scene pass across
and I think that's got to be Samuel monmo stick
has got to affect that coming across follows
up around the boards Barrett Barrett blocks
it in Justin Baron shoots rebound M through the
fre Anderson had it on his stick and couldn't
finish with a wide open net what a glorious look
for Montreal 1566 so just as teams put veterans
together with young guys so does the referee group
rosc again looking for number two and Harris might
have saved one as Johnny Gad was right in the blue
paint marenko Waits rer monteo clears out aside 21
goals in his rookie season for marenko that drive
again score tipped in front off the blast it was
bstrm who let it fly marenko was floating across
power play goal and it's two nothing Columbus NHL
game the big body 6'5 we talked about the size of
ronov who's already been involved with Jacky gets
in front of Samuel monmo watch the positioning
here it does not hit him it goes straight in it's
not if it's when for kovich as he's had a lot of
looks early in the season here's a pass in front
riny B tries to slash it in still working and mono
able to find it and frustration from the captain
the goals are going to get back on track here for
Montreal it's got to be Cole Coffield and Nick
Suzuki Leading The Way Columbus last year Dave
just nine Road wins All Season that was one of
the worst records in the National Hockey League
they are looking to go two and0 to start this
year's campaign on the road underway here in the
second Raphael Harvey panar at center right he'll
flip it in for Coffield Coffield winds up and he
just missed trying to get some Pucks in on Elvis
M leans Boon Jenner gave it away right in front
Suzuki score how about the captain Nick Suzuki
first of the year and the HS have some [Applause]
[Music] life Cole callfield to score the goal
his partner did it Nick Suzuki but it's coming
off the wall it's a good wall battle by Harvey
perard and Mike mson mson stepping up hard and
Suzuki steals that puck right on his tape makes
no hesitation at all coming out of there Coffield
coming out of the corner marenko heel Tangled Up
set up ahead for Anderson West Bas Anderson back
head and he missed could no hook weaving in lost
the buck and now Jenner some space in shorthanded
winds up stopped by Mono follow up pensy back try
mono that's a massive save as the penalty's over
yeah you heard a conversation with Jeff Gorton not
pleased with a few of the calls early right off
the draw was Coffield vers linol got it up and a
nice job there ABS going be one last push for to
five on five now quick release new hook and Ms
leakin has fonov just out of the box proov turn to
hand it off ail bstr barakov at the line rasovic
in that's across score that easy Emil bemstrom
has another Power Play goal his second of the
game it's 3-1 Columbus he's on the second power
play unit and the second power play has has done
the damage today they've scored the two goals
he attacks that seam hard and then just dumps
it off on the short side watch him come in though
he draws all the attention coming in Samuel montmo
overplays him and forgets about B ail bstrm just
seven goals last season in 55 games off to a hot
start two Power Play Goals in this one as that was
deflected twice and M lein with slowski in Front
St Lou put it Olivier driving in in front and
battling was Demitri baronov who's trying to get
a goal in his NH shell debut quick shot is oliv
tonight by monteo 30 seconds left to the period
Cole Coffield on the buck Coffield skates it in
mat Suzuki thought about the one time he's in
caufield's office mat delays R shot score Mike Mat
massive power play goal and Montreal within one
[Music] [Applause] the spark the Bell Center
needed two very different Power Play Goals
the last one end to end picking the puck up
this one the patented little wrist shot that
we've seen so often he takes a bucket of pucks
out and does that 40 50 times at the start of
every practice just that little wrist shot
posting in good traffic in front of the net
good Puck movement the Canadians player who who
best exemplifies leadership in the community
you know that trophy meant a lot to him and he
continues to bring it big time on the back end
for the halves Nick Suzuki backand dis Anderson
for mat Coffield here Circle setting up Coffield
mat Coffield right in front score the tip in front
Shan Mahan power play goal we're tied up at three
[Music] execution set plays running all over
the place moving C field up and down side to
side but it's Mike masson's patience at the top
hits C field in a good spot watch the positioning
of Manan he's positioning his body so it can
be used as a screen if CFI decides to shoot
it if not he turns his stick the other way ffield
finds the stick and slow to get up is Olivier who
was clipped but the halves are coming Monahan
in shoots big stop M leakin as Monahan nearly
doubled down to give the hals the lead here in
the third hit by Dan fourth Anderson for slavski
here slowski wanted new Hook New hook back to
Anderson space shoots big CL first leak shut
him down again and it's picked up by the halves
mat flips to SP face full Coffield cutting in
shoots kick stop M leens look it away from Morky
pass in front Pearson walking in couldn't get the
shot away then he slings it in he was tangled
up enough and the Lays Jenner got to be quick
get a shot off time winds down didn't get through
and 33 we got overtime coming up next at the Bell
Center Bahan Jenner at Center Ice were underway
in a 3-3 tie rensy on the buck Johnny good drove
through Center 25 seconds left in the penalty
em again big block over rebound leny denied by
Mono Bensky again goodro shoots deflected
jener in front that was stop bensy again
on the buck Dr up goodro WIS up that didn't
get through again still loose B it down and
out and Shan Monahan the clear play as Bas
doesn't have his stick it's behind him in
the crease and now he picks it up as Harris
has the back pedal final minute Bell Center
and over toop Suzuki drops Cole Coffield
space in Waits shoot SC OT winner Cole
Coffield would you expect anything less
on this Thursday [Applause] night oh